[Music]
greetings fellow cinephiles i am naz
perez and welcome to an exciting new
episode of rt essentials this week we're
going back to when the zombie craze
first ignited and witnessing the
evolution of a particular voice in a
particular genre that carried us all the
way to the present where villains like
the hook-handed candyman are more alive
than ever yes horror films have long
been reduced to parody-worthy tropes and
recycled frights but the artists on this
list have brought fresh perspectives and
personalities to the front of the line
and done so in the face of adversity
thanks to these films we can be
terrified thrilled and thought-provoked
all at once and i think we can all agree
that the shallow slasher has morphed
into something with far more depth and
social commentary so without further ado
these are the best black horror movies
of all time
get out i can't move
you're paralyzed
just like that day when you did nothing
you did not think
and what better place to start than with
writer director jordan peele's get out
released in the us on february 24th
2017. the film stars daniel kaluuya
allison williams bradley whitford steven
root catherine keener and caleb landry
jones kaluya plays chris washington and
williams plays rose armitage the two are
living a seemingly charmed life young in
love thriving in the bustling city
everything is just peachy that is until
rose decides to invite chris on a
weekend getaway to meet her parents at
their home in upstate new york now chris
is reluctant but ultimately agrees
because well he's a good boyfriend when
chris first arrives he's surprised by
how friendly and accommodating rose's
parents are they're almost too nice and
as we know from horror films in the past
if something seems too good to be true
that's because it is now as you can
imagine things quickly go awry and what
should have been a tranquil weekend of
bonding turns into something out of
chris's worst nightmare
oh no
no
no
no no no no no no no no no no no
i do something get out was jordan
peele's directorial debut and somewhat
of a departure from his infamous sketch
show kian peele though not entirely the
film does lean toward horror but it's
deeply rooted in satire and peel admits
that his comedic background was actually
crucial to how he approached his writing
and directing peel also took inspiration
from real life events stating that he
was once put into a similar situation
with his now ex-girlfriend but that it
didn't turn out as bad as it did for his
character chris on a budget of less than
five million dollars get out grossed
over
255 million dollars this made peel the
first black writer director to gross
more than a hundred billion dollars on a
debut feature domestically get out
became the highest grossing debut based
on an original screenplay in history a
record previously held by 1999's the
blair witch project aside from smashing
the box office critics unanimously
praised peel's work and rolling stone
actually called it a jolt a minute
horror show laced with racial tension
and stinging satirical wit an enemy
wrote that it's a smart creepy cliche
destroying horror get out also earned
four oscar nominations with peel
becoming the first black winner in the
best original screenplay category
[Music]
blade let's do this
[Music]
what could possibly be cooler than a
half human half vampire hybrid that
knows martial arts exactly nothing in
the 1998 movie blade that damn pier is
played by wesley snipes and is hell bent
on avenging his mother's death the
character first appeared as a supporting
role in the marvel comic book the tomb
of dracula in 1973 and it soon grew to
be the star of his own storylines in the
comic book version blade still hunted
vampires but he wasn't half vampire
himself he was a human that had built up
an immunity to vampire bites it wasn't
until spider-man the animated series
aired an episode in 1996 entitled blade
the vampire hunter that the origin story
that we know today was invented blade
was directed by steven norrington and in
addition to snipes featured performances
by stephen dorff chris christopherson
and boucher wright and donald logue
originally snipes had actually aimed to
make a black panther movie he had even
obtained the rights and had announced
his plans to do so as early as 1992
obviously that project didn't work out
at the time so snipes agreed to play
blade instead but not without some road
blocks in between
studios wanted blade to be a spoof with
a character far less dark and vengeful
some executives had even suggested
changing blade to be white with the
intention of appealing to a wider
audience screenwriter david s goyer who
had been hired by newline cinema refused
this idea and instead opted to keep the
authentic nature of the character and
story but what does goyer know about
writing superhero films anyways i mean
he's only written nick fury agent of
shield nolan's dark knight trilogy man
of steel and batman v superman blade
grossed over 131 million dollars
worldwide and spawned two sequels also
written by goyer the film also ignited
marvel's film successes that would
dominate the industry for the next two
decades and counting though critics were
somewhat divided on this one it's
largely considered to be a defining role
for snipes a blade reboot is actually
set for release in 2023 with the
brilliant mahershala ali starring as the
superhero
candyman you are not content with the
stories
so i was obliged to come
[Music]
the original candyman was written and
directed by english filmmaker bernard
rose and based on clive barker's short
story the forbidden the film stars tony
todd virginia madsen vanessa williams
and xander berkeley and was released in
the u.s in october of 1992. madsen plays
helen lyle a grad student writing her
thesis on the link between folklore and
the recent hardships that have fallen on
one specific housing project in chicago
helen is especially skeptical about this
candyman character who residents believe
to be responsible for a recent murder in
their community now according to urban
legend candyman is the ghost of an
african-american man who was brutally
killed in the late 19th century after he
engaged in a forbidden interracial love
affair helen's skepticism shifts to real
fear when a mysterious man that fits
candyman's description begins to soccer
believe in me
be my victim
rose gave his actors free reign to
develop their character's backstory so
tony todd went the extra mile with
candyman in barker's short story
candyman's race birthplace and name are
never mentioned so the candyman that
we're familiar with today is very much a
tony todd creation in fact it's hard to
imagine what the movie would be without
todd's imaginative input candyman
grossed over 26 million dollars and
launched a series of sequels two
released in the 90s and one in 2021 more
on that soon critics were overall
pleased with the film with the chicago
tribune writing that the action is swift
if excessively graphic and madsen proves
to be a strong-willed sympathetic lead
the new york times also called it an
elaborate campfire story with an
unusually high interest in social issues
handyman 2021
[Music]
and speak of the devil or the ghost i
should say a direct sequel to 1992's
candyman was released in 2021. jordan
peele produced and co-wrote the script
alongside with mia de costa and wynn
rosenfeld now decasa was the obvious
choice to direct this new version
following the success of her critically
acclaimed debut feature littlewoods
which was released in 1998. it is a
wonderful film and definitely worth a
watch in its early stages this
installment was meant to be more of a
crossover film entitled candyman vs
leprechaun i guess studios were hoping
to ride the coattails of hits like
freddy vs jason but tony todd wasn't
having it and if the candyman and cell
says no i mean you'd better listen so
that idea was scrapped probably for the
better and a few years later dion taylor
signed on to direct a reimagined version
set in new england but as is often the
case that idea fell apart due to legal
disputes it seemed that no matter how
many times you repeated his name in the
mirror candyman was nowhere to be found
you don't understand
okay
i i will show you
that
okay
candyman no
candy
finally in 2018 peel announced that his
company monkey paw productions would be
taking the reins with todd reprising his
role the actor was pleased with this new
direction stating that he'd rather
appeal to it someone with intelligence
who's gonna be thoughtful and dig into
the whole racial makeup of who the candy
man is and why he existed in the first
place and with todd's blessing the
candyman was back to life critics were
mostly positive in their reviews with
the hollywood reporter writing that
decosta used bernard rose's 1992 film as
a jumping off point for bone-chilling
horror that expands provocatively on the
urban legend of the first film within
the context of black folklore and
history and the boston globe called it a
cute skillfully made and pointedly
political
knight of the living dead
[Music]
chances are if you are well versed in a
zombie genre then you've not only seen
this film but you are aware of its
cultural significance and if you haven't
seen it don't wait for the apocalypse
because george romero's night of the
living dead is a must-see horror
seriously go watch it right now i'll
wait no but really this movie has
appeared on like countless greatest of
all time lists and it's considered to be
the first modern zombie film knight of
the living dead was even selected by the
library of congress for preservation in
the national film registry part of what
made this 1968 film so ahead of its time
was the decision to cast dwayne jones in
the leading role especially at a time of
serious turmoil in the united states the
vietnam war was raging on the country
was divided and racial tensions were at
an all-time high despite the
circumstances jones stepped up and
delivered an awe-inspiring performance
as ben a pragmatic leader who tries to
maintain order as flesh-eating zombies
attack from all directions
they're a lot out back too
[Music]
now this was truly one of the first
times a black actor was given a leading
role when the script didn't specifically
call for it but when asked about his
decision romero simply said that jones
was the best actor we met night of the
living dead went on to gross 30 million
dollars internationally on a budget of
125 000 i mean that made it one of the
most profitable films ever made and
critics praised the film with the la
times singling out jones by writing that
the actor quote clearly has what it
takes to go on to bigger things and the
guardian writing that romero conjures
moments of eeriness and dread throughout
and yes i mean that is meant as a
compliment
ganja and hess
once again dwayne jones delivered an
outstanding performance in 1973's
experimental horror blood couple also
known as ganja and hess bill gunn wrote
directed and starred and marlene clark
also played a leading role the film was
first screen at the cannes film festival
during international critics week where
an emphasis is actually placed on
discovering new talents from around the
world the movie follows dr hess green an
anthropologist studying the murthians
it's okay nobody else knew what the
morthians were either and that's because
gunn made it up but since you're
wondering it's an ancient african nation
that exclusively consisted of vampires
and hess possesses a mystical dagger
left over from that ancient nation now
in a strange series of events which may
or may not include hess drinking gun's
character blood that dagger actually
turns hess and his lover ganja into
blood sucking immortals
so
why the two different movie titles well
the simple answer is that the original
producers weren't happy with the box
office numbers so they pulled the film
out of distribution and sold it to the
company heritage enterprises heritage
then restored and re-cut the film so
much so that they felt it deserved an
entirely different name with alternative
marketing hence ganja and hess became
blood couple despite an unsuccessful box
office run blood couple received a
positive critical reception with a
chicago reader calling it a seminal take
on blaxploitation and horror and film
inquiry writing it's a personal film and
that its creator gun put his art and
intellect on the line i mean spike lee
loved the film so much he remade it in
2014 under the title the sweet blood of
jesus
attack the block
attack the block is a sci-fi comedy
horror written and directed by english
filmmaker joe cornish now it stars john
boyega jody whitaker alex esmell leon
jones and franz drama and features music
from the electronic duo basement jacks
and notable composer stephen price
boyega esmel and jones are teenage
street gang defending their south london
neighborhood from evil alien invaders
now boyega was relatively unknown at the
time having mostly performed in plays at
the national theater and the tricycle
theater in the uk this was his first
major role in a feature film an integral
to his meteoric rise leading to the
iconic role of finn in star wars the
force awakens and the rise of skywalker
someone please tell me what the [ __ ] is
going on what's that thing chasing you
why is the other lift full of bits of
dead people
what are you doing we need to go down i
ain't going down there's too many things
down there's out to get me get me say
bear police crazy gasters on
monsters down there
okay good let's not go down the film
takes place over the course of a single
night guy fox night to be exact pop quiz
what date does guy fox night fall on
come on you must remember remember the
5th of november cornish expertly adds
humor while maintaining shock and horror
and his movie title pays homage to the
1999 south korean crime comedy attack
the gas station attack the block was a
box office flop grossing just over 1
million in north america but that didn't
stop the film from becoming a cult
classic and garnering an overwhelmingly
positive critical response roger
ebert.com praised the film's character
development and boyega's performance and
wired magazine listed it as one of the
best films of the 2010s a sequel is in
development with cornish once again
writing and directing and boyega
reprising his role and producing
his house
his house is a horror mystery thriller
written and directed by remy weeks and
based on a story by felicity evans and
tony venables it stars juan mi masaku
sope durisu and matt smith and tells the
story of a refugee couple who escaped
the violence in south sudan and settle
in a rundown house on the outskirts of
london it's a total adjustment and the
strange evil that lurks in their new
town only proves to make matters worse
the fact that this was remy week's
directorial debut makes the film
honestly even more impressive because
it's no simple task to avoid redundancy
in a saturated genre and to do so while
balancing commentary on social issues
like immigration racism and class
inequality it spoke to me
what did it say
we don't belong here
for his work weeks took home the british
independent film award for best director
winning against florian zeller and sarah
gavron additionally masako's portrayal
added new layers of depth to the film
and the role was one she felt compelled
to take on despite not being a fan of
horror movies masaku has said in
interviews that she felt an emotional
pressure upon reading the script and
that she wanted to be a part of it in
any capacity and her conviction paid off
because this performance earned her the
british independent film award for best
performance by an actress and a
nomination for the bafta for best
actress his house was officially
released on october 30th 2020 and
distributed by netflix the la times
called it a calculated mix of migrant
drama and b-movie thrills and the film
review website that shelf wrote that
it's a multi-layered british set haunted
house film that skillfully weaves
sociopolitical commentary and engrossing
character study and unnerving visual
frights
black box
emanuel jose cooper jr wrote and
directed black box psychological horror
that stars mamadou ati felicia rashad
amanda christine and charmaine bingwa
the film was distributed by amazon and
released on october 6 2020 with
mastermind jason blum serving as an
executive producer under blumhouse
television auti plays nolan a single
father suffering from amnesia the result
of a car accident that also killed his
wife and left him in a temporary coma a
half a year later and nolan is still
trying to put the pieces of his life
back together made all the more
difficult by his incessant nightmares
and inability to recall his true
identity oh say cooper jr cleverly
weaves sci-fi elements into the film and
as the plot unfolds the emotional stakes
heighten and nolan braces for a crushing
big reveal
uh
[Music]
auti carries the audience on this
journey in a role that would be
difficult for anyone he captivates and
manages to pull sympathy with his subtle
choices it's no wonder the actor is
quickly built in impressive resume
starring in films like the circle the
front runner unicorn store underwater
and uncorked atti's performance in cake
also earned him an emmy nod for
outstanding actor in a short form comedy
or drama series black box received
generally favorable reviews with many
singling out autis performance and jose
cooper jr's direction roger ebert.com
wrote that when you watch a debut like
black box you just know the director is
going to be around for a while and we
couldn't agree more us
the girl had a second child a boy this
time
they had to cut her open and take him
from her belly
the shadow had to do it all
myself
last up on our list is the horror
mystery thriller us released on march 22
2019 and brought to life by an absolute
dream team of talent jordan peele wrote
and directed lupita nyong'o winston duke
elizabeth moss and tim hydeker star and
jason blum sean mckittrick and ian
cooper produced i mean it's like the
all-star games for cinema neongo plays
adelaide addy wilson mother to zora and
jason and wife to gabriel played by duke
the family decides to go on vacation
returning to the beachfront home that
addie grew up in addy's apprehensive
about the trip due to a traumatic
childhood experience where she wandered
off from her parents and found her way
into a creepy fun house while inside
young addie encountered a perfect
doppelganger of herself within the house
of mirrors and the shocking image has
haunted her ever since now while on
vacation addie can't shake the feeling
that something terrible is going to
happen despite her husband's reassurance
turns out she wasn't just triggered by
her past she had good reason to be
scared because four masked strangers
soon descend upon the house and the
family must fight to survive the
invasion
[Applause]
and here's the kicker each one of the
masked rangers is a perfect doppelganger
of each one of the family members it is
disturbing sometimes funny and always
entertaining in classic jordan peel
fashion us was a commercial triumph
grossing over 255 million dollars
worldwide against a budget of 20 million
dollars it had the second best opening
for a live action original film just
behind 2009's avatar and the best ever
opening for an original horror film that
wasn't based on known property the new
yorker called the film a colossal
achievement the hollywood reporter
called it a fiercely scary movie whose
meaning is up for grabs and rolling
stones described it as spill your soda
scary love that description and there
you have it friends our selections for
the best black horror movies of all time
as always we couldn't mention every film
that fits the bill but don't fret new
episodes of rt essentials are always on
the horizon i'm nas perez and thank you
again for tuning in and remember if you
find yourself in a horror film and
something seems too good to be true
that's because it is
[Music]
[Music]